[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody hello
happy Friday Joey happy Friday to you
John Luke welcome to another episode of
game dump where we play what was that
did you this where were you gonna play
some games at our game library and
decide if they're worth keeping or not
and today we have a proper n64 in the
room we do along with five of the most
questionable titles possibly ever
released at least in our opinion in our
opinion that we have in our library so
let's just get right into it
Joey what's this hot music okay so this
hot music is the menu for a game called
Milo's Astro lanes let's oh my good well
we're just gonna jump straight into this
so apparently so this is a some kind of
space themed bowling game let's see we
can select our balls go with the
that's what's cool tamari says this will
end poorly
I can't imagine this one ever end well
okay so we got selecting our player so
tell me if you want to run us through
kind of the premise of what game dump
actually is those haven't seen what
we're gonna do is curate it because it's
just a lot of crap so we're going in
here taking all these games and playing
them and giving them their due and then
deciding if they're worth their worth
keeping oh there's a hub world for this
whoa Bob Genesis you want to hear the
original GameSpot review yeah that's one
thing we do we like looking up the
original review if we can let's see oh
let's figure out where we want to go
first we got cosmic on the side we got
the oh my gosh I can't I can't read some
of this stuff on the thing we got alien
invasion you got what is this one Venus
vacation and two galaxies let's go to
Venus vacation let's hear it
while Milo's Astro lanes gets a
resounding nod for approval for its
daring immersion into subculture
parentheses I'll be at three years too
late there is very little here to
recommend a purchase and this was just
by GameSpot staff into subculture and
what exactly does it mean by this
alright it looks like the the analog
controls aren't aren't too bad you
actually have a little bit of wiggle
room here I think they're referring to
the music and the aesthetic yeah am i
you're gonna get strike on the first
move I turn on my mic
all right I got a five on so basically
this game is just bowling but in space
which is sounds ok we'll see how it like
the actual because the bowling I feel
like bowling games are all about the
physics right forces that control this
bowling icon looks like an ocarina
what's blue and for some reason
stretched oh did I just die Oh what the
hell
oh I'm bowling against the computer ok
of course he's probably guessed right
here right good lord he got what how did
he do that oh there's like power-ups on
the lane itself and that was it me too
his ball gigantic I don't understand the
rules of this so wants to know J Shaw
who is not Josh Shaw really it was also
in the chat to competing J Shaw's he
wants to know if this was made around
the time ELF bowling was popular do you
remember what your elf bullet I think a
folding was later it was for the D s
right C so that would have been around
like 2002 maybe no it was the same year
now really bowling games alright okay I
can zoom in oh look at that
mr. SAS ins already saying next game oh
god damn it guys trying to figure out if
I can actually control the oh my god
I feel the same way
so we're not gonna spend a whole lot of
time on each game we're gonna give each
game about 20 minutes or so 20 minutes
kind of the max but we can certainly
digitally yeah
just like oh okay there we go we can use
the C C controls some once no what's
with the telephone paperboy a paperboy
is one the ones from playing and we
thought it was the funniest looking one
so if we wanted to there we go
almost the spare dizzied earth says tech
and bowlers better
oh not gonna I'm not gonna disagree with
that mr. J so wants to know what are
using to capture the answers before game
holy [ __ ] we have a framemeister which
is a Japanese scaler I don't think I'm
gonna win this or meas I'm gonna go one
more frame and then we'll try it we'll
go to a different area good one main
milos after lane why are you playing
mile oh boy I thought she looked weird
like come on come on come on come on do
it
Oh bad better it better the last time
what what was that I press the Z trigger
and suddenly exploded you activated your
all oh maybe that's how that maybe
that's thank you make it bigger
okay let me try that maybe like there
are certain certain mechanics for each
ball possibly
let me try here thank you some those
power-ups oh yeah
whoa her hand you see that
wait will haven't like these things in
stretch lions do that I'm gonna go back
to the lobby yeah please I am very sure
so we went to where did we go oh we went
to Venus that first time let's go to
Ghazi cosmic mr. between cosmic and
galaxy I don't know so what are the
chances go to the galaxy so I'm inclined
maybe listen to their requests well we
can't never mind
galaxies closed off okay mom let's go to
games what's this one hyperspace Tamura
says who's he to cycle through specials
how does he know this it's probably
because he's a man why he's a Milo after
lanes world champ
he owns the record I don't many people
don't know this about tomorrow okay so
there's triple ball there's what is that
one like a diamond ball I'll mosey for
specials ante specials yeah it's more
just dropping out it's not professional
Milo's a strolling player our knowledge
shut up yeah Khan dude okay here we go
here we go boom so what was what special
is that that was the triple sin the
upper left corner so we're fighting
against Milo
so let's girl let's try it let's put
some spin on that ball shall we yeah but
specially gonna use oh shoot oh wait
well i'm apparently i'm using whatever
this one is can you go faster okay let's
see how milo does it come on Milo this
is your game show us what you got put
some spin on that ball he showed you up
yeah you didn't use it level of gaming
says dump or no dump I'm feeling a very
heavy dump coming on yeah whoa do you
need like I could take Oh
finish the stream first but okay sorry
oh we missed
there's the clone ball the Cloquet so
the clone ball is the one that I use
double strength of a ball and impact
boost let me see which one's there
I guess I use my special though you can
only use it once there we go just use
them all there we go all right thank you
tomorrow for the the hot knowledge I
want to take that sound bite tricky go
use his oh he did my lies smug face so I
don't think there is a story to this
game is there I can't did you see
anything no I mean well so there is
they're just they just happen to be in
space for no reason like the first line
review it's a shame there aren't more
bowling games and on consoles today I
can you wonder why I guess back in the
99 they there weren't that many now I
mean I see after we the we let's go to
many bowling yeah and none of them did
as well we bowling still one of the best
bowling game other apparently there are
anti specials treats a pull of slime
that decays Wow alright so you can like
do something dirty Ballston there's a
shrinks of ball so you could play aunt
eyes during opponent's turn how do i do
all these though it doesn't look like i
think i have to collect them let's girls
go let's go
well Milo still has a bomb so he can
like messing me up apparently he said
during enemy turn yeah I don't think I
have any right now but like during
during my turn you can see mile ahead
though had the bomb right but I don't
think they're gonna do that right
computer is not back that smart is it so
I wasted all of your specials now but
it's like I can I can still collect more
during my to riot all of them couldn't
even do it
wolf Sajan yeah this game Xbox one the
hot new I actually made that just
backwards compatible all right try to
get those hot specials here
I get both of them Jane get any of them
they just disappeared
[Music]
you're welcome Joey coming please stop
playing this really well ready oh I'm
done I'm so done with this game
okay hold on let me let me just go okay
I got here we go boom
okay into with the spare we only we only
made it 12 minutes into this one first
thing apparently the people made this
meter at home gym or gym 3d quit I'm
gonna make sure we get the full mile of
Astro lanes experience get that nice
music okay we are we are did this all
right um actually
how about Shadow Man I have a feeling
that that one might not be as terrible
as you think Shadow Man this is one that
a lot of people the office were telling
us about
I have like never heard of this game
before but we have it on like multiple
systems I guess it's uh not on a it was
based on a yeah it's more saying shot
man is a keeper yeah like we just
probably because it look the Box are a
little kind of strange
it's I've never heard of it yeah like on
the surface it kind of looks like one of
those like weird shovelware games but we
could be completely wrong that's the
that's the the magic of this show we're
you might find things that are just
really really good
hello Shannon man anytime shadow man oh
there we go oh let's go to new adventure
the game is rumble pack compatible
unfortunately we have neither the rumble
pack or the controller pack so we cannot
save nor feel the force feedback from
Shadow Man oh yeah
some moonlight sonata' who turns up my
didi my heart Mary Ann Nichols truly
love them all but the immortal power I
thought we've been assaulted come find
that their bodies still beating organ of
the soul
the ritual annoyance in Ohio I am the
rest and must therefore perform that
bloody ritual upon myself there your
hands you can listen to what I have to
say how did you find this place
who are you my name is legion for we are
many
the immortal power that you seek does
exist
it does indeed lying within the soul
within thirteen oh we're playing Dark
Souls is this baby show me you must play
all three darts are the dialogue of this
game not what I expect I know 929 in 64
game they say Nintendo was kid-friendly
high growth Kelly this is a lie there's
a lot of stuff happening right now
the patented in 64 balls
Wow okay yeah that must been a pretty
convincing sales pitch because he just
looks like alright sure time to die man
we've got we gotta we gotta go look like
we're in New Orleans or something I
think that's awesome man that bad is us
level of gaming this game is about
demons if we dump it will just reappear
on the shelf that's probably true we
might not be able to get rid of this
magnet
I had a dream shuttle mine are you bad
dream I did like the five are here The
Herald of the apocalypse
Oh an ancient prophecy tells of every
turn of a great evil today excite more I
agree there should be more games have
they ever made any like modern ones to
use within both well you are the only
one who can do anything about apparently
like the scene blink of them on the bed
looks exactly like the crime scene by
the way like Callie is like really into
like murder that's good to know so she
has all this like weird knowledge about
things like I'm not gonna ask why and
the Dark Souls that evil dude is Nayan
protected how Dark Souls is uh we got to
recover the Dark Souls precursor it's
great
are we just gonna watch like 10 minutes
of what this game is mature oh man okay
so what's that on the corner we got
rockin shells some bullets I'm not sure
what that left one is Cassidy wants to
know if I also like murder I so coming
around to it there's they're just run a
lot is a lot of story in your just
giving us an exposition dump right now I
well it's good thing right because it's
making us one over continue playing it
because we have him video was a control
our character yet I hope the games like
the this intro is sold me I hope the
gameplay is good that's the question the
[ __ ] of the universe all right there
we are okay so we can jump shoot yet oh
you okay so we got crosshairs here okay
I got a little inventory a mile you can
read it looks like we can Crouch can't
move up or is that now by tomorrow
thanks for popping I see yeah glad we
could show you some some Shadow Man
please make it please oh there we go
what if that's where we just got stuck
all right
whoa it's not that see Oh always it
those don't like kaku's or something oh
yeah yeah I think you're getting hurt
you can hear like my heartbeat or those
hearts oh maybe there's another heart I
think no that's not a heart well it was
like beating no I think that was the
cocoon you like your thing inside the
cake yeah yeah shoot it okay yeah Jay
Chou wants to know have you guys played
gun dump or no dump uh haven't played
gun personally I know we have a copy of
gun maybe we'll get to that at some
point cuz I know that one's got a mixed
reception some you know like that game
some people think it's kind of whatever
[Music]
his texture changed well maybe that was
intentional it's all part of the full or
oh we can actually grab onto ledges and
climb take some hints from Laura Croft
can't jump can't grab onto that I have
no attack at least not yet wait oh I can
roll yeah if I move and then press down
on the deceit see controls yeah yeah
he's hand over hand there's a dog
those birds it's more these hearts or
whatever they are haven't seen anything
yet that makes me feel like a shadow man
though it's kind of running around right
surround environment we get magic powers
this is the picture on the box shows
like a skull he's holding a skull I
haven't been able to hold of skull you
know we should check the review what I
didn't realize this was the ledge okay
cool let's see hello doggie cruised by
Erik Wolpaw
I seem silly to malign a game about the
undead by calling it lifeless but that's
exactly shadow man's problem really
ouch oh we got a cutscene here Nitti hey
Mike
Oh Sam Mike how could I review your
offer
how could I ever refuse you Agneta
between the line you'll find Elsa's
escape wouldn't look out a place on
Steam I actually believe there is a
really well I got like a remastered
version or not even remaster but like
high-res five anything good about this
is the graphics are unexceptional okay
okay so I really got to get to the Dark
Souls before the bad guy I understand
that but where do I find him okay so
those things are
I tried apparently this is a
collectathon game like the dark souls
are equivalent of like stars and yeah
the stars are like the notes from banjo
kazooie Dark Souls here but you're
collecting copies I gotta say the story
trying very hard to make something out
of nothing something to show you
okay and Mike yeah go and get them dog
yeah that seems to be kind of like the
crux of the review is sort of like the
idea behind this game is cool but then
it's like presented as like a Mario 64
these old Joe those the jockeys are
these things and I need to be able to
open them somehow okay or Jovi javi
look at that no loading cool seamless
gameplay hey doggy
oh there's a dog whoa no I ain't shoot
it went right over him
I ain't realize that a gun now sorry I'm
sorry I have to do it you have to kill
them oh no I tried to make things right
by letting letting them eat you I mean
okay we this games about murder right
wait oh my god
shadow born at the confluence of worlds
to walk between life side is without the
meeting that my part in living possesses
here in dead side where the darkness is
manifest at the edges of reason hello
God I stepped forth upon the writhing
separating surface of the dead side
serpent what sleep is here what dreams
there are in the ankh you according they
must have taken the style of directing
the comic away
you only think okay so are we dead now
yeah it looks like when you die you go
to a different world and you can still
like maybe it's like a shadow
Bailey son of a gun if it's a way cooler
looking gun - why is a dead man need a
gun for
it was like okay
until that man there you go oh and then
I steal his soul or something like that
nothing can die well I guess they're
already dead but names take all the
bullets I like how even though he's he's
like in this shadow world he still
decided to keep his cheating's on Callie
said she won't last a port dog murder
they murdered me hello sir I would
appreciate if you calls me by my help
might want to go by Michael you are my
shadow man mom I told you this before
we'll get to that which is force to
deliver papers in the underworld
I need to know more about shadow man's
history how are you looking on time how
much much more gentlemen we have ok so
gives us a little bit more time see if
there's anything worthy you think he's
been sideways I really hope so
can't really tell but he better be
exactly how a man should be holding it
Oh Jay Chou how long do we do this for
like an hour yeah about an hour and a
half yeah give give each game like
around 20 minutes so gives some good
first impressions or bad ones
[Music]
isn't yeah it's probably probably sure
there's another whatever those things
are our hearts okay there's a thing here
[Music]
but these guys for the shoes
[Music]
he's dead cool take their souls
I seem to have unlimited bullets which
is fine guess things don't need to be
really explained when you're dead
roll em says there's apparently sequels
at this game on the ps2 really yeah was
just Shadow Man 2 or was it like
oh here's all these guns sideways yes
it's called Shadow Man second coming
with the s in second replacement you
[Music]
let's see what we gave it oh there's a
review for the second one yeah despite
its flaws Shadow Man 2 second coming or
two and coming will likely manage to
draw you in especially we get to the
creepy aesthetics and earnestly engaging
story earnest oh wait how is he gonna
move yeah they gave it a 6 point 9 um so
you know came along one of those ropes
again but I have the gun in the hand and
now he won't actually climb Oh go
forward man oh yeah I can okay boy did
that note say hey serial killer records
October 9th and e9 wherever possible
includes backgrounds criminal profile
sightings and prime suspect for each of
the following the Lizard King the repo
man the video nasty killer home
improvement killer I'm assuming since it
doesn't have the name it's a Tim Allen
and then Jack to the sequel to Jack okay
so I do have a gun a shadow gun uses
shadow bullets that's why I never run
out and then was this good cadeau I have
nine of these oh yeah let's make it our
way over here Kelly saying she's still
wished in 10 don't call this flat - yeah
but then you don't have any like think I
was good how are you gonna like
differentiate the two when you speak of
them yeah I guess you'd call us latching
- wait does anyone call driver three
just driver that one's right
or fear the freer then for stick
yeah the fan birthday
okay this games kind of giving me a
headache oh the soup sofa me
I know then choose which hand to take it
out of oh boy
those who oh I thought that that was
coming out them though blue things are
my bullets
alright spend about 20 minutes Joey I'm
gonna say we should I think shot a man
deserves a reboot reboot yeah they
should take a shot the constantly
shouting Matt you're dumping and they
should they should try and like do this
justice actually yeah like I don't know
what they could do but not make it a
platformer make it more like would you
want to see like a Dark Souls kind of
thing come out of this yeah like Dark
Souls mixed with like Max Payne or you
with this you oh wait oh you just got
burned out what happened something we
die when you die in the matrix I was
gonna say like this this environment
cutter reminds me a little bit of doom
the new doom yeah like I can totally see
it being like kind of like that but a
platform or not right like a 3d action
game of some sort okay are we are we
dumping this yeah I feel like a lot of
people in offices would also be mad if
we dumped it it's so it's a weird enough
game that I think it's worthy of keeping
yeah like just that from the intro alone
yeah it's pretty cool it's interesting
it says Shadow Man 3 the return of Mike
it's not Michael it's Shadow Man okay
let's go gaming has to go oh you're
watching on your phone and mana is
dedication thank you so much for joining
us yes yeah all right we're not leaving
but we're getting rid of Shadow Man want
to go to next we got this one virtual
chess 64 to will chess 64 it's hard to
see but this has just got the the worst
cover I've ever seen you won't you lay
it in game I'm sure so yeah we'll find
out
Macari says yeah I rented this game when
I was little and finished it it's pretty
awesome Shadow Man yeah the mark
[Music]
what has Titus done oh my god so yeah
that's I guess the black queen and the
white queen
why you have a fish oh all right
take this software yeah well they made
Superman 6400 those guys oh my god
Welles did they do let's see here okay
so let's start demo or done games that
people would recognize here the quest
for Camelot a Blues Brothers game it
looks like crazy cars decreasing up oh
they did incredible crisis though
incredible crisis is awesome oh that
yeah you you're telling you about that
game like not - okay I guess we're just
jumping straight into this chess yeah so
people know how to play chess right it's
a fairly simple game I'm wondering why
so I'm assuming once we like get into
like a battle then characters will start
coming out yeah
I've ever seen well yeah oh god that was
my calling apparently wait what took me
that was a bishop why is he like an elf
looking creepy ass thing oh yeah oh
whoops oh boy they're all saying
apparently the he watched the game drums
play this is it is it bad bad have you
ever seen out the Star Wars chess game
no I haven't um yeah there's this old
Star Wars chest I mean they did a
similar thing where it would like cut to
these animations of like the Star Wars
characters like murdering age
can't see my pawn against the bishop get
him get him man
oh he's gonna stab him with the oh they
just shattered beside the pitchfork okay
so this is the Queen oh hey goob you're
just in time for virtual chess 64 all
right okay what do you do a hot chess
strategy um gee you know
do you like to like get out like a
knight first or you know like what's do
usually I like I like using the knight
salon but they just got their Queen out
like way she just came straight out um
actually you are in you are in check
right now oh shoot wait hold on there we
go
let's guy here yeah get out of here wait
a second I can't do anything
okay queen out here ah dude just stick
your Brooke it's just a castle so wonder
what happens when you actually take a
piece with the rook yes I'm happy I got
a queen in my house okay if I move no
she's gonna take that if I do that oh I
should have moved it this is not going
well
the the CPU is playing very aggressively
I know well that's what he do is be
aggressive back right yeah sure I'm play
Cheston forever here oh yeah she's going
she's leaving
that's their check sound oh it's like
the the switch sound that's actually
where they got it from you check your
friends list okay this is just bet oh
look at we're re-enacting the the box
art for this oh oh no I don't like this
at the rabbits George what's this is
this my night no that's my it's my king
okay see you later
[Music]
Oh ha I'll take it man okay hold on
what if what does that sound
that's the cancel sound fairly okay I
just move the pawn for now hey it's
different for each character why have we
got today because I have to move the
King yeah so far we dumped Milo's Astro
Lane which was a very bad bowling game
and then we played Shadow Man but
decided to keep that one because it was
actually not bad interesting I don't
know if how well hold Robledo beginning
we thought was interesting enough that
it was worth keeping for now oh the
Queen's are at it you lost York we are
really bad at chess by the way I don't
know if I made this clear early on I
just want to see look I just want to see
the animations that's all oh just did he
run back over him
yeah probably yes yes no mo like check
it if he was dead or not
oh my check dang it
[Music]
no I can do the swap with the brook
right no no let me do it what were you
trying to I guess want you when I have
the King back here I can swap positions
with the rook
they might not that's a specific rule
that not all chess games why would you
know let me do it so they probably won't
let you do that this is that's the rule
in chess though this is stupid then it's
the worst game of chess ever played even
though you know I Bob Genesis cuz you
already moved your you're King oh wait
what was that is that what happened like
a wizard she turn him into hearts was
that the rook or not that was a bishop
that queen is unstoppable Joey oh [ __ ]
Joey guy do something drastic here I
can't move the king
this is bad thing it's the king
Oh straight oh he's just gonna get you
by a shark I guess Makar he's asking I
wonder if the game had cheat codes this
game doesn't even have a menu like it
you booted up and it just jumped
straight into a game of chess how do you
know how you get a menu okay preferences
I'm on beginner number one apparently
virtual chess 64 Oh
let's choose the board no it's just the
3d we can rotate the block whoa why the
power of 3d it just flipped it it just
turned it around it and do anything else
okay yep according to game spot.com
never heard of it there is a series of
cheat codes we can view their next move
really mm-hmm
if you press a C up C down up down left
right during gameplay you can view the
anticipated moves that's a definitely a
cheat right there okay so let's open up
the debug menu I'm not really sure what
that'll get us let's do it was it
upsy-downsy left C right C up down the
Frank hope d-pad or probably d-pad there
we go a debug menu huh
okay okay so we can what does that mean
so we can control the maybe I'm not sure
if it we were able to do this before but
you can control the the board with the C
the C buttons
that's just confusing now Bob gentles we
were on the hardest level yeah I know is
that why it we just got rats okay
am I still white okay I am just flipped
it around for some reason well I see
what you're trying to do huh
I'm gonna try to take my my pawn wait
what what's going on it's trying to move
up oh it's because it flipped it and now
my controls are reversed when I turn it
around
Oh No wait hold on how do we reset this
oh just change the board back restore
boards yeah there we go
okay now the controls should be fine
hopefully yeah Errol I'm not sure what
the point of doing this is makes it more
interesting at least right hey at one
point we had 64 people watching whoo I
think no one else can watch or leave
ever are they gonna go
did I break it okay there we go so is
that bar on the left my chances of
winning I don't know what that is okay
there's apparently they're thinking
because now we're on the hardest
difficulty right
oh I mean put some cheats while we're
playing
so was it up down down left right well
I'll see you up see down up down left
right
[Music]
we'll be displayed at the bottom of the
screen they're not even going you know
we're saying switch I agree let's just
get rid of this one yeah yeah this is No
yeah by virtual chess you suck we're
dumping alright let's get right into a
battlezone
rise of the black dogs oh I didn't even
notice there was a subtitle for that rob
was telling us that like he had played
this yeah I wasn't I wasn't sure if he
was talking about battle tanks because
that was another game around the same
time let's find out though no controller
pack detected that's fine
wait continue without saving yes
oh-oh-oh that was the button color
another crave entertainment classic
which one did they do Milo's ass rolling
out again and climax battlezone prize of
the black dogs okay let's go oh there is
multiplayer but unfortunately we don't
have yeah you have one controller with
us right now that's fine I'll see what
single-player is all about whoo
there's arcade mode there's pilot
commander sometimes like it difficult to
yes pilot we can be the Soviet Union
also black dogs yeah let's do that
yeah that's the name hold on can I go to
Jupiter it's right there well you
probably have to reports indicate that a
top-end ESF scientists has been captured
by the Soviets and is being held
prisoner at one of the five outposts
somewhere on the moon located scientists
destroy any opposition rescue the
American scientists there's gonna be a
massive resistance so we got to be
careful insert Rumble Peck now don't
sorry I'll have to go in a barrel aim
just so that they'll stop asking us for
it
music whoa whoa hello said a cool she'll
find you guys yeah taste it all this up
this is actually the controls are
actually really good here like you uh
you move forward with the d-pad it's not
inverted which is uh disappointing for
me if I could change it Bob Jones says
he played a ton of this on PC what you
think of it oh you want the card yeah a
cockpit of you I just wanted to see if I
could change the yeah whatever
definitely not let's go let's go let's
go oh he says they came out with a
remastered version really Wow okay so
see my
can't control this thing it's all this
stuff happy on the moon
Oh
this is all my stuff I can't tell
are you late were you at the review we
have said battle zone rise of the Black
Dog
the audio is not great
the music's kind of II Alex out warning
it was critical
I'm just trying to destroy this basis
this where this was supposed to do
something blew up by the way it could
have been my own base do you play
battlezone yes we are
actually no but I watched some things
get Nadia Bothan mic volume although
with the game audio a little bit sorry
about that
[Music]
laser Viking who says this isn't
paperboy don't worry I'm still a
paperboy good beginning to paper coming
right up
oh my god do you play inverted or non
bird you me yeah I like my inverted on
like space flight Sims like this it's
got I think I just fell through the
world by the way oh I'm on foot now whoa
no more like flying hmm is really where
I'm okay with it
mission failed I was killed what did I
think of a battle zone for psvr oh I saw
it looked it looked interesting go back
to missions slides
let's try arcade bmary be an American
I'm sorry Ani today geez
I would say mission so we got turrets
I wonder the differences between
the factions pink
I think maybe yeah I'll assume just
different missions nice controls are
actually pretty decent like the strafing
and like Moomins like responsive not
clunky really she's really surprising
he's a little bit have you got another
one over here do I have another weapon
besides this minigun whoo nice
let's get really up close and personal
yeah all this earth right there is that
one picture of Earth everyone uses
hello so farts disease pretty basic
turrets it might be because I'm in
arcade mode I want to see what happens
when I get out on foot though what if I
can still destroy these things what's
this one mortar
it's a mortar ooh wow I don't know where
it is okay let me go this guy oh I just
blew myself up good job
all right how many 40 degrees north uh
there okay boom no yeah arch up way more
how do I know if it's gonna fire it's
still going apparently just like in the
ground did work
I hit it bouncing it's gonna [ __ ] hit
me now oh why can't I can detonate it Oh
[Music]
boom now I think we need but that's the
whole reason mortars I think I'm getting
it yeah there we go all right let's try
get the socket and turrets
so that one's how many meters hunt 200
meters away how much does the other one
I don't know and there's no like reading
on the mortar thing Megan's I can tell
where it's just like in real life Joey
you got an estimate two calculations
well I hit it wait they hit it no I
didn't hit it oh it's in a crater arrow
and not really much of a theme just n64
games we don't really have much of a
theme with our entry for games this time
unfortunately although oh my god we are
we go we have a pretty good theme we
think for next or should I say the next
time we play wait okay
I'm one foot now let's go pick up the
turret I have a plasma rifle let's do it
oh my god well you shut the ground
actually the bullets are going backwards
no that's that's a church she didn't
mean no baby no he's shooting at me
right yeah no he is but look at the look
behind you
maybe those are the one his bullets just
going straight through me now I get like
that that's your bullets going behind
you why I destroyed the turret anyway
I'm good how do I get out of this crater
now let's just walk oh yeah it's the
moon poser oh there's another guy here
died
it's pretty barren okay well I guess is
the moon after all was he gonna put on
here look a sniper rifle
you're getting you shot up we won fine
oh you're dead just vaporize it's a
tough game how much time you got
I think we're almost out of time for
this one Oh mission failed by God did
you get a new high score score this is
not the easiest game to jump into like
this no um we're trying more just get
like a sense of it though uh nuts I
didn't beat nuts score oh what a shame
nuts in and Bend climax Heights try the
Soviets let's go a commander and then
the Soviets oh good
oh they're on another planet yeah the
golem ambush turned to the mountainous
terrain in this area set an ambush for
Senate ambush for and destroy the
American recycler okay who are we on the
son
oopss who saved these games as a great
question I mean no one saved them we
just didn't throw them away immediately
oh my god the fog I guess this makes
sense since we're on an alien planet or
just like a random planet I can have
like different unit types whoa well this
is too much for me could your commander
so you can like command units like yes
so there's the American outpost okay
it's very far away a little dude this is
battle zone for the n64
oh it just ejected by now Joey
where is my where's my tank please
can I get back in turn around oh my God
where is it I he ejected really far I
think it's 500 meters away yeah
apparently you can link build building
as a command units that's pretty awesome
actually I don't know if I can do it
while I'm right oh wait no I can
follow me everyone follow me
recycler Wow
fighter follow me everyone follow me
this is really cool
okay scavenger follow me
can't get in one view please I want to
walk there we go
I think I got in you were killed what
okay so I think I just got run over by
one of my own recycler planes place to
end battle zone what do you feel I kind
of want to keep it okay honestly uh it's
it's not it's not a terrible game I'm
very very surprised like there's a lot
of elements that we just finally figured
out then got killed by like it's almost
like a what like a real time strategy
kind of thing sort of yeah I'm like have
your battalion of units and whatnot it's
kind of neat yeah let's keep it alright
not dumping that all right and finally
the PSD resistance
[Music]
I heard the music from earlier and very
excited smooth 30 framework this is 66
per second maybe
[Music]
cowbell the animation section look at
that
Oh sick yeah the models maybe like butt
ugly but actually pretty good you you
have any petals on his bike by the way
from paperboy
yeah like the graphics are pretty mad
but this time we're charm to this did
you play the original at all yeah oh it
can be paper girl whoa name I just keep
that player yeah choose a difficulty we
got Easy Street middle road or hardway
[Music]
hoping you'd say highway we got Alice's
RV Haven or Alphaville let's start
without the middle no we can go here
actually no okay let's start with the
first oh wait whoops oh okay I guess
we're doing this one okay so we got five
six houses to hit all right hopefully I
can get it paper boy where are you
delivered newspapers right that's all it
is okay oh dude okay well I'm just
wasting the wall oh damn it Rowan I'm
dude oh my gosh that's what the I can
pause and then like read and change the
camera oh that's what I thought it was
stuttering I also zoom all the way out
if I want to hit each other out
oh yeah perfect I am out of the papers
almost Mike Vardy was saying that he
really liked this game 64 yeah
apparently I just have 10 more papers
now it's a little clunky oh it is
[Music]
alright Scott keep going I'll keep going
around block no you don't want paper
I'll if you look at the map okay yeah I
see it how am I gonna get from this side
though what's on the other side yeah I
can do tricks Oh paper girls ill some
sick Ollie's you got one paper left no
it's fine I just get more afterwards
right
I don't now I'll have to pick them up
smack okay I think I'm figuring this out
so those papers right here that I can
just pick up and so if I run out it's
not it's not the end of the world
she's like fired yeah alright let's
let's go to Alphaville start from there
and figure I kind of figure out the
controls or the oh yeah that's some more
straight line it's a coldest act that
goes in nowhere little dude says this is
so weird
I agree so I guess you want to go as
slow as possible probably right
[Music]
bang I think I might be able to get a
higher score if it's farther away yeah
I'll say so pick up some papers here I
got 29 papers to go shucks I'm just like
oh let go and go to the mailbox right
mailbox
oh the dog I feel like it's a smaller
target oh yeah [ __ ] you dog alright that
is the theme of this dream dog murder
whoo it's gonna get points off these
shirts and just get poisoned foot
throwing in that stuff okay
the houses and then just sort of also
try and
yeah whoa thank you dead
Killa get these garden gnomes alright I
need to save me save me oh yeah I got
three laps only go I've got 10 seconds
no that went straight through it just
get it yeah
only got five out of six though I would
celebrate two murdered a man Kali says
as a family Bert old paper boy I think
this is an abomination and vote dump
thank you no come on we have it he
played one game tornado watch in effect
apparently because this is in the middle
of Kansas please tell me there's
tornadoes I can pick you up nice
actually went through yeah we throw a
while doing while doing trick can you do
that now I can do it I hate the cactus
oh stop fighting have a paper
[Music]
let's move a little bit faster here jube
apparently agrees with Callie yeah if I
record all you eventually hit that
there's just garbage cans in the way
[Music]
record right up grab that I'm out okay
yeah there's lying there there I'm on
the other side of the road I can't get
to it for some reason now the way
chickens just go on the road and do a
back flip
ah
[Music]
anything saying this is my last chance
to do this I'm just gonna heave all my
papers at it oh yeah there we go so I
remember you were telling me that you
actually have a paper route at one point
right my cousin had a paper route was it
anything like this no did you actually
have to throw them at the doors or no
you have to go up to the door and might
actually put it open up the screen and
put it in oh that's so fun yeah kind of
creepy because it was like super like
late yeah where it's like so dark yeah
so you're just like walk up to some
person's house
there's some weird houses on the way
lady
Janelle lady just rekt you so I take it
you weren't on a bicycle then right no
no by all there's a ramp there okay I
need to go back today
what's my life like a video game I had
that miss it really is like not that
interesting like doing a paper route you
get a lot of money though like like for
some guy lives in a tent here my hair
well I got a rocket how can I use that
[Music]
papers 25 seconds
oh shoot deliver to this tent nice these
are camping grounds looks like it that
one yeah cool okay can you do you think
you can get to that other one I got I
got a book it make sure you don't run
into anything move of cars no I can make
it I can make it
[Music]
you don't even hear now throw now nope I
have a rocket I'm not sure how to use it
though are people recounting their
Paperboy experiences yeah
Mork I says I had to deliver them on a
bicycle and I couldn't get off to
deliver them because it take too long so
I had to go on on my bike through the
front yards could just walk
no that ain't too long it's all about
efficiency ma'am
[Music]
this is a beach okay easy
first move it lifeguard
[Music]
I want to try to see if I get those
power-ups see what they do
whoa that's actually I can actually get
a lot of speed smack I just ran some
body builders it's gonna force me down
this way is a rad you can't turn around
nope family can't go forward either sick
wait you can't I can't no really can't
screwed okay I got five out of six
Jim take the job
a Rowland says if they made a modern
date paper boy would you be delivering
packages instead or no you'd be like a
post meats person yeah mate yeah you
work for like some some app company yeah
every three much you have to move to
each Oklahoma because they shut down
yeah right now the venture funding all
right how are we on time we've been
going for about 16 minutes
it's almost time to make our decision if
I'm not still playing bye then
[Music]
all right okay you need to get this
house whoa you are getting almost run
over lack of safety package boy I like
post mates boy is something like Kapow
it was perfect oh okay got that one I
think I commit I'll make this one
yeah it just turns me in that direction
we can't do anything stop it you have to
make this jump I just throw all your
papers at it yeah 99 package boy does
have the same ring yeah okay we're at
Tesla town okay so the thing is on the
boxart for this there's like this guy
like this dude oh yeah there's like a
volcano at some point like in the
background so I'm just wondering like a
pretty sure future levels we'll have
that I could be delivering papers yeah
like oh Kanak Iran's new victim charm to
this
some there's plenty of opportunities for
me to get electrocuted here
others no move powered by electricity
I got it oh we got six papers here gimme
well what a fireball that real fireball
year I was like a devil gravestones here
some reason gargoyles this is a
dangerous place I thought this was Tesla
town not like a girl like a cemetery
everyone's dead for some reason place of
canyons here whoa
got it
I'm actually not surprisingly enough I'm
not hating this as much as I thought I
would or I'm not disliking it right I
need more I guess how many more do we
need you need fifty six so I need four
more just go back to alpha bill means
full readership okay let me deliver
perfect
[Music]
phors all I need right speed down the
highway nice
Oh move it I've got snacked it's a world
record speed run for paperboy 64 I'm
definitely sure that exists
[Music]
[Music]
April boy anyone
seen any maybe for the original maybe
but not this one
we got a bonus definitely the original
paperboy or paper girl to attempt
obstacle course I'm assuming it seems
like 10 minutes 45 seconds for the
original good I'm I'm inclined to
believe that she is making her own
headlines and then giving paper central
this is fake news she's got her own
paper business yeah where she just makes
everything yourself and then demands
people pay her for it are you doing
great so far is that why is that that
log one more yeah
we got gold somehow all right Joey okay
I am gonna I'm actually gonna not dump
it you can see don't face because he
dumped it but it's what's the last
what's the last stage now that we have
enough this doctor Tesla's castle wait
it's just like a is there a narrative to
this the evil doctor says destroy it
what well you have to get through like
you know you're so like the paper girl
she goes through her normal routes and
also and she gets like she just has to
go into dr. Tesla's neighborhood right
and she uncovers this terrible secret
that he's creating a monster and only
she can do it because she's the only one
that has access to that that area is a
boss battle whoa oh god alright maybe I
can maybe destroy oh really
[Music]
okay
I say I know what happened hit that and
then one of the the coils become on
electrifying that could hit those Oh God
crash oh dear laughter help dude no
that's his health my health is on top
left or top right yeah he's back he's
banging it back he's trying to fix it oh
my god no gonna involve the boss battle
no no no no no no that one stopping
stopping stopping
yeah yes
that was weird local paper girl saves
destroys dr. Tesla's monster you win now
play medium or hard for more exciting
levels wait that was the game that's
that's the last that's the end no we
have to play on the harder difficulty
for more I will do that maybe later
because I really I kind of want to keep
this I don't want to dump it well I
think paperboy is a very like it's like
a recognized franchise and I think yeah
it's worth keeping for like I wanna say
is for historical reasons but it's not I
don't think it's as terrible as yeah I
think paperboy is is someone along those
lines it like it looks pretty bad but
has like a certain charm to it I think
and like yeah ok can we keep the please
please
alright well it's gonna do it then yeah
so let's recap which one's did we decide
to keep which ones so we decide to dump
[Music]
battlezone Shadow Man and paperboy and
[Music]
three out of five which is not how this
is I feel like maybe in future episodes
we'll we'll do a second or no I want to
say like only one of these we can keep
thinkin we haven't actually played most
of these right but virtual chess 64 and
milos
master lands a big steaming pile of
domes yeah just get rid of them
thank you everyone for joining us for
this episode of game dumb uh-huh we're
try and do it on Fridays when we can so
who knows we'll do an X but we'll we've
got some cool ideas for the next one
yeah they're pretty exciting so uh
thanks for tuning in we do live streams
here every weekday at 11:00 I know that
Monday once again Mike and Jake are
gonna be doing up G's to make sure
Brighton for that and have a great
weekend guys
see you guys later
[Music]